[Music]
and tonight we continue
to follow the ongoing david versus
goliath brawl
that's broken out on wall street tonight
as a group of small
small-time main street traders taking on
the big
hedge fund goliath who got caught in a
massive
what they do is they short stocks and a
short squeeze
and they lost billions after retail
investors they banded together to buy
stocks like gamestop
amc blackberry and others now how's the
establishment responding
to getting beaten by the little guy well
they've been freezing trades on apps
like robin hood and even censoring
online message boards
and get this we're now learning tonight
treasury secretary
janet yellen right there she was paid a
whopping
eight hundred thousand dollars from the
hedge fund
citadel which is one of the funds at the
center of this controversy
now ask yourself we're going to hire a
speaker for an event that you have
let me see who could i hire oh janet
yellen we'll give her 800 000
uh we have to face a simple truth here
there is
there always has been too many financial
wall street and political ties with wall
street
and people in government i'm not saying
anything nefarious
i'm saying hmm i wonder if they hired
her for great knowledge and interesting
speaking style
biden white house downplaying the
payments and the entire gamestop story
but it's already
now drawing bipartisan calls for
investigations on capitol hill
somebody knows a lot more about this
than me the author of
the trump century he's the host of the
number one show on our sister network
lou dobbs tonight the one and only lou
dobbs you know
i think janine and your your monologue
scare me more than my own monologues i
don't know
um good to see you lou uh
great to see you sean all right can we
break this down
hedge funds shorting stocks it's part of
a process
little guys banding together now looks
like then they stop
people can't cash out at this point
things got ugly today
the word rigged we heard it a lot under
the previous president didn't we
this is a rigged event and that is robin
hood which has
all sorts of great positive wonderful
connotations
uh its ceo today deciding to disrupt the
market
and particularly to the disadvantage of
those who were
buying stock in a company that big money
had said would could
only decline i but this is a complicated
story
more complicated than it's being
presented because there are a lot of
hedge funds on the other side of these
trades standing with those folks who
started this
acquisition effort buying up the stock
as the shorts
primarily from the hedge funds moved in
but they're also those hedge funds on
the long side of this shot
so it gets complicated the actions taken
by
robin hood and several other inter
internet brokerages today
to change the rules of of
wall street right in the middle of this
event
probably means that robin hood will very
likely have
it could in fact lose the current owners
could lose control of that company
the sec has an absolute responsibility
to move in and to stop this nonsense and
i want to say that two class
action lawsuits have been filed against
robin hood
for what they have done here over the
course of the past 12 hours
and it's it's good to see what is not
good to see
is in a presumably active biden
administration here
uh with the likes you know of you know
all sorts of uh market uh regulator
inclined advocates in the administration
they've done nothing the sec hasn't
stepped in
finra hasn't stepped in all of the the
exchanges
are mute this is an outrage and it's an
outrage it's got to be fixed
and this isn't the stuff for a uh you
know a commission
of of some sort this should be an
outright
in my opinion criminal investigation wow
very informative lou dobbs uh
don't forget lou dobbs tonight it's
number one show on our sister network
the fox business network luke thank you
thanks for joining us good to see you
joining